ja hallo ich bin der Harald
wir sind logistikschule
wir haben uns sehr intensiv damit
beschäftigt mit den blickout und so
Beitrag dazu ist Rezepte geschrieben von
einem record Kochbuch
und die möchte ich darauf hinweisen wie
man dann kochen kann ohne Strom einfach
nur veranstalten wie das Rezept so
funktioniert
und
wie immer paar Sachen einhalten muss man
kochen
so wir haben schon ein paar Sachen
hergerichtet ich mache jetzt ganz
bewusst ich habe alle Rezepte was man da
drinnen im Buch drinnen habe ich mit dem
fonduekocher kocht bis auf das
Fladenbrot klar aber man kann nur eine
veranschaulichen dass man mit einfachen
Mitteln kochen kann stinken normaler
fonduekocher mit einer Aufsatz drauf und
handelsüblich dabei ist einfach nur mit
einer brennpassten gefüllter
heizbehälter
wir machen schon die nächste ist auch
überall zum Kaufen einfach
abbrennpastendose die brennpassten Dose
brennt ungefähr 22 Stunden also man kann
da schon recht früh kochen damit und es
immer wieder befüllbar
aufpassen bitte wenn man wenn man
kein Gas nimmt oder wenn es geht kein
Gas nimmt und sowas
da braucht man
einen Löffel oder
Holzstapel nimm Pasta raus sind meine
Vorsicht gegangen
und es brennt schon das Ausblasen mit
dann stellen wir das ganze drauf
natürlich kann man das auch wenn man es
hat in ein Kochtopf machen wichtig ist
man Kochtopf dass er dicke Platte unten
hat weil sonst da hat die Brennpaste
nicht sondern wirklich mit einem
schmalen Boden und mit einem dünnen
Boden und dann funktioniert das recht
gut wir haben das von türkische
der Firma auch mal bitte was anderes
so wie es mir
vorstellen weil was ist das wichtigste
beim Blick hat immer schade dass mein
Kühlschrank mein Tiefkühlschrank
und dass ich Ernährung physiologisch
ganz ganz wichtig unterwegs bin
aber mit komplett anderen Zutaten weil
Gott
mir festgestellt haben das ist ein
Kühlschrank drin das muss weg das war
ist aber ganz simpel einfach wir haben
schon man merkt sehr schon dass er
beworben wird
tun nichts anderes wir machen ein
Eintopfgericht das an äußeren
Eintopfgerichte
und schicken das einfach zusammen wir
haben ein leberkasten
ist egal was man da hat und was man rein
tut was der Kühlschrank oder was
weggehen
nicht alles nicht alles
zur Verfügung hat was man braucht was
man Mensch braucht
ernährungsphysiologisch ganz ganz
wichtig ein Bild schmecken soll es nur
nebenbei
und natürlich tun müssen sie sagen
Kochbuch keine keine
Kran ankommen meistens sondern einfach
nur noch los
vergessen dass wir nicht mal Kühlschrank
oder
fleischsocken ich kann ja kein Leber
ich habe jetzt
Paprika
man kann natürlich jedes andere Gewürz
annehmen das ist selbst so schlimm
und das soll jetzt ein bisschen
das Wasser
ich habe jetzt kein Kochtopf
gerade soll sein so wir
an guten Kessel erstellt das Rad
schaut dass das geschlossen ist
und lasst es einfach nach
Dreiviertelstunde
fertig machen bzw aufmachen bitte den
Topf runterstellen von der Flamme es ist
heiß
das nicht mehr benötigte
passiert
und im Prinzip braucht man nicht
in einer Schöpfer
d
Flüssigkeit drinnen
wichtig wichtig ist wirklich nur die
Pflaumen aus nichts angreifen nicht
verbrennen
ganz gutes Gericht aus es ist einfach so
gegeben
wie man es würzen will ist komplett egal
wie man es mag und in erster Linie
geht's
ernährungsphysiologisch dass man sagt
man hat seine Kohlenhydrate man hat
seine fette
braucht recht wenig Wasser dass man
nicht als Extra kochen muss sondern dass
man nur als eine schicken muss kochen
muss und sein schmecken lassen ist guten
Appetit okay